افادت وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه بان
ضابطين وجنديا قتلوا في معارك جنوبي قطاع
غزه وبهذا يبلغ عدد القتلى المعلن عنهم
469 منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي كما اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه خمسه جنود بينهم
ضابط من سلاح المدرعات بجراح خطيره في
معارك خان يونس بقطاع
غزه ونشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول يمكن لسكان البلدات
الواقعه على بعد عه كيلومترات من الحدود
مع غزه العوده الى
منازلهم معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد هل لديك تفاصيل
اكثر حول هذا الاعلان من الجيش الاسرائيلي
عن امكانيه عوده سكان البلدات التي تبعد
عه كيلومترات عن حدود غزه العوده الى
منازلهم نعم هي تشمل كافه البلدات الواقعه
خارج الشريط الذي يصل بعمق 4 كيلومترات في
منطقه غلاف غزه الجيش يقول بانه قد امن
حزاما او شريطا امنا في داخل قطاع غزه
يتيح لسكان هذه البلدات العوده الى
بلداتهم من المناطق التي نزحوا اليها وان
وضعهم اصبح امنا على حد تعبيره بمعنى انها
لن تشهد ربما قصف من داخل القطاع او
محاولات اختراق من قبل المقاومه لهذه
المناطق لكن سكان هذه المناطق يقدر عددهم
مع الذين نزحوا من المناطق والبلدات
الاسرائيليه المتاخمه للحدود مع لبنان
بنحو
125000 من الاسرائيليين منهم نحو 70,000
من هذه البلدات هؤلاء حتى الان مترددون
وغير مقتنعين بان الامن قد تحقق بالفعل
رغم بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي سيتضح نهار هذا
اليوم وغد فيما اذا سيعودون فعلا ام انها
خطوه من جانب الجيش لتعزيز الثقه بان
قواته تحقق انجازات ماذا عن اخر ما تقوله
اسرائيل بخصوص خسائرها في الحرب وكذا جديد
صفقه
الاسرى نعم اخر ما اعلن بهذا الخصوص
واعترف به الجيش الاسرائيلي ان ثلاثه من
جنوده بينهم ضابطين او جنديين في كليه
الضباط قد قتلوا وان خمسه اخرين بينهم
ضابط من سلاح المدرعات قد اصيبوا بجراح
خطيره للغايه في معارك بجنوب قطاع غزه
وايضا في شمالها وان هذا العدد قد رفع عدد
قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه توغله
البري في ال 26 من اكتوبر الماضي الى
123 قتيلا بين جندي وضابط وبذلك اصبح
مجموع قتلاه منذ عمليه طوفان الاقصى
والحرب التي اندلعت في السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي ودخلت يومها الس 26 اليوم
469 قتيلا وهو يشير الى ان قواته تواجهوا
قتالا ضاريا تحديدا في منطقه خان يونس
وانها لكنها تواصل تقدمها ببطء في هذه
المناطق وقد دفع بكتيبه هندسه من اجل
تعزيز عمل يات الكشف عن انفاق سواء في
شمالي القطاع او جنوبه وكذلك بلواء اضافي
الى منطقه جنوب قطاع غزه لانه عازم على
توسيع نطاق عملياته البريه في منطقه جنوب
القطاع ويعتقد بان منطقه خان يونس ستكون
هي الحرب الفاصله في هذا القتال هذا كله
يترافق مع الانباء التي توالت في الايام
الاخيره حول المفاوضات التجاريه بين
اسرائيل والوسطاء سواء مصر وقطر والولايات
المتحده من اجل ابرام صفقه تبادل جديده
للاسرى بهذا الخصوص واحد المقترحات
المدرجه يتحدث عن ان يتم الافراج عن 40 من
الاسرائيليين الاسرى في قطاع
غزه وبشكل خاص النساء والاطفال
والمسنين والمرضى الموجودين هناك وذلك في
مقابل لثلاثه اضعاف هذا العدد من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين يتم اخلاء سبيلهم ويشمل ذلك
وز اسرى فلسطينيين وزنين اي من القياديين
واصحاب المحكيات العاليه وان يكون ذلك على
مدى اسبوعين من وقف اطلاق النار او الهدنه
ولكن هذا هذه المفاوضات حتى الان لم تحقق
اي اختراق او تقدم هي فقط اجواء تحاول ان
تبعث على التفاؤل وذو الاسرا الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في قطاع غزه يواصلون احتجاجاتهم
في تل ابيب هؤلاء يطالبون الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بان يكون هناك وقف تام لاطلاق
النار خشيه على ارواح ابنائهم واقربائهم
المحتجزين من القصف الاسرائيلي سواء
بالطيران او بالمدفعيه وايضا حتى لو كان
ذلك في مقابل اخلاء سبيل جميع الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في السجون الاسرائيليه شكرا
لك الوضع لا يحقق تقدما حتى الساعه نعم
وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا
من رام الله شكرا لك